今日な今日は 4回目でございまして
テーマとしては中道が悩みのない心を育てるという中道の心の悩みのない心をどうやって育てますかというテーマですが
前回はこのこのプラスポジティブエネルギーとネガティブエネルギーのことを話しましたが
あのマイナスの暗いことばっかり話して
話は途中で時間切れになって終わったんですね
ですから 前回の後半申し上げてから
今日のテーマに入りたいと思います
前回の後半というのは
何が明るい思考ですかということなんですね
ただ単にお金を儲かるために
会社でうまく仕事をできるために
家庭はものすごく安全にもう活動できるようにとかね
子供たちには受験合格できるぐらいとかね
それぐらいの目的のポジティブ思考っていうのは欲を中心にしてるんですね
何か儲かりたいと 欲を中心にしてると
それはポジティブ思考だと仏教では言わないんですね
いくらかはうまくいくんです
そこでどこかでぶつかって
もう壊れてしまうんです
例えば 会社のために自分がポジティブ思考を持っちゃうと
自分がその世界だけに自分の気持ちを集中しなくちゃいけないんですね
会社には目的がありますし
その目的を達成しなくちゃいけない
その目的のためにいろんなものを犠牲にしなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから 堂々と他のものを犠牲にして
この会社の目的を達成するために
その人は自分の人生をかけなくちゃいけない
そうすると 会社にいる限りはいいんだけど
でも人の人生っていうのは 24時間会社人じゃないんだから
一生の中でほんの一部だけ会社人間だから
他のところでものすごいネガティブになってしまって不幸になるんですね
ですから 一部不幸になって
ほんのかすか何か成功しましたということはあまり正しくないんですね
例えば世界一周回りたいんだと
自分がいろんな国で 2 3ヶ月間住んでみて
まあゆっくりのんびり世界一周回りたいんだと
それはいい考え方でしょうに
別に悪くないんです でもそのために私は決めたことは確かに実現してみますと
まあああだこうだと このまあ下らないことは考えませんで
片っ端から自分持ってる全ての財産も売ってしまって
会社も辞めて あっちこっちから借金もして
世界一周して終わっても
それからは大変な苦しみが待ってるんですね
ですから そういうのはあまりポジティブ思考じゃないんです
そういうのは単なるもう暗示の一種なんですね
ですから ポジティブポジティブやっても
そういう何か一方的な目的を作って
とにかくその目的だけだけ達成しようという風な明るい思考は気をつけましょうと
で それはすごい一時的なんですね
例えばやれば何でもできますよとかね
そういう言葉ありますね
やれば何でもできますよ
ですから やりなさいと
そこはその言われた人が真面目に受け取ったら
大変大変ひどい目に遭うんです
例えば子供がなんか勉強に自信がないんだと
受験受験に自信がないんだと
そうすると先生たちやら大人たちはもうそういうのは
あんたはね この前こういうことをやったんではない
この前こういうこういう風に成功したんではないかと
あの小学生ではこれぐらいいい成績出したんではないかと
その時は元気でやったんだから
もう何のことないんで
やれば何でもできますよと
できないもの何もないんです
言ったところで もしその子がそれを真面目に受け取って
自分には何でもやればできるんだと思っちゃったら
何やるかわからないんですね
それからは だからその受験に自信なかった分は自信がついてきてよくできたっていうのは
それはもう大変ありがたい結果なんですけど
じゃあ私にやれば何でもできるんだよと思って行動しちゃうと
どこかで大変な不幸に遭う可能性はありますね
それは世の中の人間を見るとよくあるんです
例えば 何か商売始まるそこでうまくいっちゃう
で あ 私がやれば何にも何でもできるんじゃないか
この商売成功しているんではないか
じゃあ 2番目の店も開きましょうと 2
号の店も開いてみるとか
もっと拡大してみたら
もう何でもやればできるんだと言ったところで
すごい借金をして 後で夜逃げするしか結果がなくなっちゃうということもあるんですね
それはもう過剰自信でやればできる
やればできるという暗示でうまくいくわけじゃないんですね
やっぱりそこら辺でいろんなことを考えなくちゃいけない
いろんな原因結果があるんですね
そこは考えで 例えば商売を始めてうまくいったと
そこで自分がどれぐらいその商売に力を入れていましたかと
それも計算しなきゃいけない
私はもう一日夜寝る時間以外
全部この店の繁栄のために頑張ったんではないかと
仕入れは自分で一人で行って
あっちこっち行ってもう一番安いところから仕入れしたんではないかと
商売をうまくするためには
こういうこういう自分で工夫したんではないかとか
そういうのも計算した上で
そういうふうにやれば成功するんだと
でも 2番目の店だったらどうなるんですかというと
自分の時間はきちんと半分なくなるか
2番目の店に注がなくちゃいけない
あるいは 2番目の店は完全に他の人に任すか
どっちかでしょ そこで任された人が同じ性格じゃないんだから
その店はものすごく失敗する可能性もあるし
あるいは自分の能力の半分を分けちゃいますから
こちらの収入は半分になって
あそこの収入もそこそこになったところで
まあ結局借金は払えなく払えないような状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから やればできる
やればできるじゃなくて
物事をきちんと合理的に具体的に把握して理解する必要もそこに必要なんですね
社会状況 例えばなんで日本でバブルという現象が起こりましたかというと
みんなまあまあ私からすごく悪口言いますけど
経済についてはみんな音痴ではないかと
世界一経済的な大国なのに
経済知識に対して音痴ではないかと
それは子供にでもわかることで
こんなものは何かおかしいではないかと
ずっと何でも上がりっぱなしで上がりっぱなしにあるわけない
すべての価格っていうのは
ありとあらゆる条件によって成り立っているものであって
価格っていうのは実際それしないものであって
ものの価格っていうのは全然実際しないものなんです
その時の気分次第なんですね
例えば円の価値にしたっても
もう気分次第なんですね
ドルの価値っていうのは
アメリカ人の傲慢さ次第なんですね
それだけのことで 別に決まってる価値がないんです
そこはまあ実際するようごとく考えちゃって
でも大変みんな大怪我してしまっちゃったんですね
いまだにそのあまりの怪我が大きくて
もう立ち直れないんですね
ですから このやっぱり物事を冷静に
具体的に 客観的に考える
考えて冷静に判断する
落ち着く それもそれは抜群のポジティブ思考なんです
それ まずそれを覚えておいてください
ポジティブ思考というのは
自己暗示かけることだけではないんだと
ただ まあ物事 ああそういうことで
そうなった こういうことでこうなったと
冷静に物事を考える つい結論出さないで
ちゃんと結論を出れる自然に出てくるまで
ちゃんと物事を並べてみる
原因とか ありとあらゆることは
この世の中にあるポジティブ思考っていうのは
こういう ことをやりたい
目的作る 山を登りたい
それだけ それからとにかくもう登ってやると
やればできるんだと そういうのはもうポジティブのように見えるんだけど
すごい危険性あるものなんですね
じゃなくて もう一つ 例えば新しい店を開けたいんだと
でもお金もないんだと
で これぐらいお金必要
それはもう借金すればこれぐらいの一月これぐらい払わなくちゃいけないという
まずちゃんとしたデータを取ってみる
自分で店を必ず開きますかないかと決めることはしない
それで他の状況を考えてみると
いろいろ明るく いろんな情報を集めてみる
と判断してみる 自分の能力と
その自分の商売に手伝ってくれる人々の能力とか
どれぐらいやる気がありますかとか
それを全部まとめたところで答えが自然に出てくるんですね
やる気はやるしかないんだと
まあ大変高い借金しなくちゃいけないんだけど
まあこういうことだからやるしかないな
それは正しいポジティブ思考なんですね
残るのは自分で行動するかしないかということだけだから
その分はじゃあやるしかないんだと
じゃあやってやりますと
その場合は危険性ないポジティブ思考
ですから  第1番目はポジティブ思考のそういう合理的で具体的ですごく客観的で冷静に物事を見るということ
いわゆる自己暗示かけない
その前しっかりした知識
知恵を持つことなんですね
で 知識も知恵ももう判断もあるんだけど
なんとなく実行にちょっと行く自信がない時だけ
まあやるしかないんだと
やってみなきゃわからないんだから
じゃあやってみましょうと
山を登る場合も 全部基礎準備もしているんだと
全部もう情報は取ってるんだと
いろいろ訓練も積んでいるんだと
まあそんなに険しい山ではないないんだけど
他のものは登った経験もあるんだと
まあ必要なものは揃ってるんだと
今もあるんだと まあやるしかないんだと
それだったらその山を登ってみる
それでいろんな危険なことに出会いますけど
それでもきちんと立ち向かって
こんなところで負けてはたまりませんよということで
なぜならば全部状況揃ってるんだから
で登ればいいんです そういうのは失敗のない
危険性のないポジティブ的な考え方なんです
で 世俗的なことはそこら辺で置いておいて
まあ私たちは精神的なことを喋る仕事だから
まあ欲の世界のことはそこら辺に置いておきましょう
まあいくらでも喋ろうと思ったら喋られますけど
まあ時間もったいないですからね
で 人間っていうのはこの
どういうわけかわからないんだけど
暗い方向へ考えられるようにできているんです
どんな人でも やっぱりいくらニコニコと笑っていたっても
根っこは暗いんです ですから
この表面的に暗い方々はあまり心配する必要ないんです
この顔でよくニコニコと笑って
ものすごい活発的に行動して
もう大成功を収めている方々
人々も根っこはすごい暗いんです
ですから あまり気にする必要ないんです
私だけ暗いんですよとかね
ただ 自分の暗さが表に出てるだけ
他の人の暗さが表に出てないんです
ある人のことなんですけど
すごい明るいんです で
言葉はものすごく上手ですっごいもうユーモアばっかしで
何を喋ってもその中でなんかすごいこの鋭い
もう背話時の聞いた言葉いつでもあるんですね
だから聞いたらすぐみんなもう笑ってしまっちゃうし
人を笑わすには言われないんです
この人は そこでみんな大変喜びますね
この人が来ると そこで何聞いてもなんか冗談言っちゃう
言い返しちゃう どんな問題
大変な問題があっても
まあすぐなんか言って
それでまあ冗談でそれを誤魔化したりして
みんなもう泣く下げてしまったりつつったりする
そこで直接こういう質問をしたんですね
なんであんたはいつでもそんな態度でいるんですかと
いつでも物事はまあ面白い
おかしく見て 冗談で人を笑わせたりして
一生懸命人ばっかり集めて人の中でいるんですか
ただそうでないとなかなか生きていられないんだと
一人になったらものすごい大変だ
大変みたいです 一人でいられないんです
ということは あまりも暗いんですね
心の底は このあまりも暗いんだから
ああいう風に頑張って自分が生きてるんです
で 外の人々を見たら この人はもう嫌になるほど明るいんだ
元気じゃないかと だからみんなその人のお世話になってるんです
だから人のお世話をすること
人を笑わせてあげることで
彼が自分の暗さ 暗さ 暗さに気づかないで済むんです
そこで僕は個人的に知ってるすごくお金の金持ちの人々がいるんです
で まあかなり小さい時からもう知っていて
もうお金何もなかった時からもう
で すごい成功しているんです
それで明るいかというと
結構明るいことは明るいんだけど
まあよく人と仲良くしたり
まあ人の機嫌取ったりとか
まあ商売人ですから 心の中っていうのはものすごい徹底的に貧しいんです
すごいもう嫌になるほど精神的に貧しいんです
経済的な感覚で貧しいんです
すごい貧乏という心を持ってるんです
そこで私たちはこの一緒に生活していた時でも
まあ私たちほんのちょっとお金もらったら
それで何か買ったりして遊んだり食べたり
もうすぐもう終わってしまっちゃうんですね
その人はそういうことをしないんですね
厳密に計算する それで嫌にならない
ものすごい鋭いですね
計算でも物事の考え方でも
その人何か買う場合はすごい鋭い
ものすごいシャープに計算してやったりする
それ同じ活動を成長したところで
もう大変成功してすごい金持ちにはなってましたけど
後で僕はもう何年間経ったところで
すごい金持ちになったところで
ちょっとどこか行くと
途中でまああの人にもちょっともう会って挨拶でもしようと行って行ったら
まあどこかで開けていなかったんだけど
まあちょっと車で待っていたんですね
待って その時喋ったっていうのも
ただ今自分にはお金はいっぱいあるということで威張っているだけで
生き方はそのまんまなんですね
ものすごい貧しいんですね
あのすっごい強烈なケチな性格というのは全く直ってない
もしかするとそれ直ったら彼がまた一生懸命商売しないかもしれませんし
で 前はまあ 100円 200円単位で決着をしたんだけど
今はまあ 100万円 200万円単位で決着しているだけのこと
ただ 0が増えただけで
ですから そこで理解してほしいのは
この私は言いたがっているのは
人間っていうのは根元がみんな暗いということなんです
それで仏教では それにはちゃんとした論理
方法説明あるんです で
全てのものは無常なんですね
全ては無常であって不完全なんですね
これ私のものというふうなものは何一つもないんです
すぐ消えてしまう だから今いろんな店で売ってるいろんな品物がありまして
買おうとしたら値段というのはものすごい高いんですね
もう分割で買わなくちゃ買えないぐらい高いもんなんですね
そこで買った瞬間であの値段はずっともう 75%減っちゃうんです
値段消えちゃうんです
中古品になっちゃうんです
箱を開けたら 何も価値がなくなっちゃうんです
でも自分がもう何年もかけて
またお金を払わなくちゃいけない
価値ないものを 何か何が問題があったら
それまた売ってお金半分でも戻してもらうことは不可能なんですね
それは事実なんですね
どんな高価な服を買っても
一回着たところでもう同じ値段では売れないんですね
中古品になっちゃうんです
僕 すごいかわいそうな立場なんですね
それで心は納得いかないでしょ
納得いくんだったら まあ一応仏教は究極的に理解しているか
完全なバカかどっちかなんですね
納得いかないのは一般的な普通の知識人の考え感覚だと思いますよ
もう何 10万円でも払って買った買ったものは
一旦身につけたらもう値段は消えちゃう
まあ値段消えない品物もありますけど
この宝石みたいなものとかね
装飾品ですか もう でもあんなもので何の価値もないでしょ
何の価値もない 人間の頭の中で価値をつけてるんですね
あの金とか銀とか金属に何か価値があるんですかね
食べられないし 何にも価値がない
ただこのまあいろいろ機械を IC とか作る使ったりする場合は
この あの 何て言いますか
コンダクターとしてはすごくいいんだから
抵抗ないんだからね ないわけじゃないんだけど
抵抗が一番少ないんだから
そういう工業的な まあ利用価値はありますけど
ダイヤにしたってもね
カッターとして もう利用価値はありません
それ以外何もないんです
ただの石ですから ですから
そういうものの値段は変わらないじゃなくて
いくらか安定しているとか
それはなぜかというと
人間の意識だけなんですね
頭の中だけ それは頭の中にある価値だけなんです
で 例えば私たちはスーパーに行って
ちょっとした鶏肉 100グラムぐらい買ったんですよと
それはそこら辺もう忘れたとなれば
カラスはそれを奪っちゃうんですね
カラスに見つかっちゃったら
もし野良猫に見つかったら
もう戻ってこないんです
ということは価値があるんです
価値があるんです 野良猫から見たって
あ これはもういいものだと
カラスから見たっては
これはもう立派なものだと
人間から見て あ これはいいものだと
そちらには価値があるんです
じゃあ皆様買ったダイヤを置いておいてください
この外で と まあ子供さえあまり気にしないと思いますよ
価値がないんです 大人だけなんで
それ盗もうとするのは
カラスは絶対持っていかないんです
野良猫なんかはオシッコかけるかもしれません
価値がないんです  それでこの我々の生き方っていうのは
まあそういういつでも無常に出会っていて
せっかく買ったものは自分から消えていっちゃう
せっかく我が子だとものすごい愛情いっぱいで育てるものを
毎日毎日自分から離れることをやってるんですね
自分は我が子を育てようとして何やってるんですかというと
自分から出ていくようなことしてるんですね
成長させるということは
なんかすごい矛盾なんですね
せっかく育てたものは
自分のものになるのは一番楽しいなのに
そうならないことは育て方なんですね
ですから いくら立派に子供育てても
そちらにものすごい不満というものが残っちゃうんですね
子供は立派に育てれば育てるほど
独立したところで心に開ける穴の方が大きいんですね
人生っていうのはそういう風なこの矛盾なんですね
会社にしたっても同じことなんで
会社で自分がものすごくいい成績
いい成績ばっかり出していて
すっごい元気で仕事をすると
ものすごい自分が充実感得ちゃうんですね
存在価値 自分がいることは
この会社にとっては大変な存在ですよと
そこで退職したところで
ものすごい穴が開いちゃうんですね
これからどう生きていればいいんですけど
わからなくなっちゃうんです
だから一歩成功すると一歩すごい穴が開けてしまっちゃう
会社にはもういらない人間になった人はもう会社に行くのも嫌で
そこでクビになったなったと聞いたっても大したことない
感じないんですけどね
じゃあ他のところで職を探しましょうということになりますけど
成功する人はまた違うんです
成功した人はクビにしちゃったら
その人はそれで人生終わり
大変悲しいんです だから全てのものは無常であって
もっと簡単に考えちゃうと
我々食べるご飯にしたっても完璧じゃないんですね
だから どんな美味しいご飯を食べても
完全な満たしたという感じが生まれてこない
次は何を食べようかという欲望が生まれてくる
物事はそういうふうにできているんです
そういうふうにできているんだから
心の中で ああ もうもっとやりたい
次に何しようかという欲望で終わっちゃうんです
あれでは物足らないんだと
皆様は品物を買う時でも同じことなんですね
自分の購買力 買える力あるところの品物を買うんだけど
いつでももっと上のクラスのものをそこに並んで置いておくんです
ですから もうちょっとお金あればあれ買えたのにという気持ちがあるし
家具買う場合も立派な家具があるんだけど
自分の部屋には入らないんだから
じゃあこれぐらいでいいやと
でもあの家具はもっといいなという気持ちがそこにあったりする
そこで そこでまた不満が生まれていく
それから買ったものは買った瞬間から中古品になっちゃいますから
そこにまた不満が生まれていく
そういうふうな存在ですから
根元から暗いのは当たり前の状態になっているんです
物事は無常であって 不完全であって
それによって心の中でよく満たせてないという苦しみが感じている
気がつかないだけ 毎瞬瞬間瞬間ごとに我々はそれを感じているんです
問題は気づいているかないかだけ
そこで仏教ではまあ究極的な明るさとして言っているのは
それだったらもう諦めようと
物事を追ってきて満足を得よというこのくだらないこの走りをやめなさい
走るな 何をやっても同じことをやって
よく見てみなさいと ちょっと高い次元から
すべての存在に対してちょっと笑っちゃうんですね
やれやれ何やってるんですかという感じで
その人は明るいです 我心のこの欲望ですか
満たしてない気持ちだけは消してしまう
満たしたいという気持ち
それは仏教の世界で その前にもっと具体的なところは説明します
何が明るい思考かと それは論理的な仏教のすごいきつい
ちょっとわかりにくいかもしれませんけど
論理的にそういうものなんです
だから私ははっきり言うのはもう頑張ってみてくださいと
人生は成功するかもしれませんだけど
不満だけはそのまま残りますよと
ということなんですね
それは暗く聞こえる明るい思考なんです
暗く聞こえるのは やっぱりやればできるんだよという
この何の意味のない妄想に基づいている人々だけなんです
やればできるって言ったら
やってもできないものはいくらでもありますからね
世の中で だからこのやればできるということに
私は 私はこういうふうに言うんですね
やればできるんじゃなくて
人間ができないことはやらないんだと
人間がやること やらねばならないことっていうのは
人間にできることだと
だから なんであなたに自信ないんです？バカバカらしいではないかという
私の教えはそういう教えなんですね
このアホと 何やってるんですかと
人間っていうのはできないことはやらないんだと
僕にたまに聞く人々言うんですね
何か仕事でああだこうだとかね
失敗したらどうしますかとか
まあこんな で 一回あまり人は相談に乗ってこないんです
僕はもうすぐもう大丈夫だ
大丈夫だって背中を叩いてあげませんだから
いきなりこの あの 何 何言ってるんですか
いい加減にしろと そういうふうな感じで言うんだから
そういう答え求めてないんですね
だからさらに僕怒るんですね
あなた自分の問題自分でも解決できないくせに
答えまで持ってるんですかと
私に言わせる答えまで
いい加減にしろと 人をなめるなと
自分で答え知ってるんだったら自分でやりなさいと
ということにまたさらに怒ってしまうんですね
だからこの私の言い方っていうのは
そういう言い方で 人間はできないことはやらない
やってることは全部人間にできることであって
それもできないというならば
もうアホしか言えないんですね
それで理解しないんです
理解しない場合 僕はこう言うんですね
あなたの会社はあなたに空を飛んでみろと言われたことがありますか？と
あるいは海に潜って この何も道具もなしに魚でも取ってこいとか言ったことはありますか？と
あの 例えば出張にしたっても
会社にお金ないんだから大阪まで走ってこいと言ったことがありますか？と
ないでしょ？そんなことは
いくら会社にお金なくたっても
出張に大阪に行かなくちゃいけないんだったら
やっぱり交通費は出してくれるでしょうに
もし新幹線に行くお金を出してくれなかったならば
その日で日帰りにしなくてもいいでしょう
会社はあなたには新幹線にはお金は出せません
普通の東海道線なんです
だからそちらに乗って乗り換えて乗り換えて行きなさいと
あるいは夜行バスでも乗って行きなさいと
でもすぐ明日会社に帰ってくださいとは言わないんだから
だから頼むのはできることなんですね
できないことを頼んだならば
なんかからかってるだけなんです
だからなんでそこに自信がないかと
と僕はわからないんですね
人に空を飛べと頼んだわけじゃないんだから
アメリカ出張だったら泳いで行けという人がいないんだから
そこでこういうことが出てくるんですね
例えば 1 日でできないぐらいの量の仕事をやる
やらせる場合あるんですね
この資料を全部読んで
明日レポート書いて書いてこいと
そうすると この決まってる時間の中でそれはできないんですね
ちゃんと見たら それできないんだ
だからなんで自信がなくなっちゃうんですかね
どう見たってもできないんだ
あんな仕事を頼んだ上司がバカであって
なんで常識ない上司に対して自分が自分のせっかく大事な自信失いますかと
その代わりにあんな上司ってのは常識のないただの人間のクズやと
やれやれ そんな人の指導の下で仕事しなくちゃいけなくなった私も大変だなと思って喜べばいいんだから
その場合はまあまあ私は仕事した時はもうすごいキツかったんで
私は仕事をそんなに経験ないんだけど
で ですから 一番下のレベルにいたんですが
一番高いのレベルにも攻撃するとか攻撃する
まあ大学でしたから まあ僕らは普通の教師で
まあみんなもう大教授たちが一番偉いところでいて
もうもう近寄れないんですよ
部屋にさえもう簡単に入れないんです
あまりも偉くて でも仕事帰ってきたところで
私の仕事の範囲やら能力やら
ちょっとでも違うなと感じられたら
何のことなく行くんです
全部資料を持って行って
なんでこれ私に頼むんですか？と
そしたら私はこういうこういう分野の仕事をする計画ですと
そういう約束ですと これは私に関係ないんだと
いきなり言うんです 他の人に任せなさいと
言ったら じゃあ誰に任せばいい？いや
なんとかなんとか人いるんじゃないんです
それはその分野の人ではないかと
というか あるいは先生が
まあそれでもまああなた方にも経験必要だから
ちょっと頑張ってみればどうですか？と言われる場合もありますね
どうせ大学だから 先生としての関係はない
いつでもありますから
そう言われると あなた方もやっぱりそれ勉強した方がいいと思いますよと
ああ わかりましたと それでやるんです
できない仕事を なぜかというと
これは私の勉強にもなるんだと
そういう時は失敗は全然恐れません
研究結果は他の専門家から見れば
これ違いますよと言われたって何のことないんです
すごい堂々としているんです
なぜかって 僕はもう自分の勉強にやったんだから
間違いのは当たり前だよって
間違ったところを教えてくれるのはあなた方の仕事ではないかと
すごい平気で自信満々でいるんですね
結果は失敗なんですけど
だから自信を失う必要ないんですね
その場合は だから やればできるんじゃなくて
人間にはできないことはやらない
そんな常識なんですよ
人間やってることは全部できることなんですね
スポーツに出ている人は
スポーツの世界では理想的というのは
アマチュアの場合はオリンピックなんですけど
どんな人にもオリンピック金メダル取ってほしいって思う人はないし
なんとなく能力見えてきちゃうと
若くて才能を見えてくるんだと
そうするとちょっと希望しておきます
その人 ちょっとチャレンジしてみたって悪くないでしょ
それによってストレス溜まっちゃって
どうしようかとか みんな病気かかっちゃって
せっかくの金メダルもなくなる
金メダルのところが予選で落ちるんですから
あれはバカバカらしいんです
やってみてもいいんです
ですから 一般的に言えば
次のポジティブ思考っていうのは
失敗は恐れるなということなんです
失敗については全然恐れる必要ないんです
堂々と平気でいた方がいいんです
そうするともうすぐ次に失敗しない
だからそこでちょっとしたちょっと危険な言葉には
まあ失敗したっても何の反省もなく
何の勉強もしないのは
まあそれはもう とんでもない
もう高慢で無知ですから
そういうことじゃないんです
自分が精一杯頑張ったんだけど
こういうこういうことで失敗しましたと
というきちんとした客観的な具体的な理解なんですね
それやったら次に同じことをやると
そういうことはやらない
失敗の原因はなくしますから
問題ないんです そういうふうな立場で失敗は恐れないこと必要なんです
また話戻ってしまったんだけど
一般論に申し訳ないんだけど
で この根っこから暗い心を明るい方向へ持つためには
仏教ではいろいろことを教えてあります
で ただの商売繁盛というのは全然仏教で考えてないんです
家庭円満とか お寺のお守りにはそういうのは書いてありますけど
あんなものは仏教の目的じゃないんです
で そんなくだらないことで
どうでもいいことで で
に 力絞る必要はないんです
そんなことは まあちょっとしたことで
商売繁盛なんかはね ちょっと頑張れば得られるもので
ちょっとだけ落ち着けば家庭は円満になるんであって
バカなことさえやらなかったら
商売はもう悪くなる必要ないし
なんか最近倒産した なんとかなんとかダイヤの宝石屋さんいたでしょ
もう完全に狂ってるやり方でやっていたんだから
あれぐらいの常識ないでよく商売するんだから
まだ日本人もよく物を買うもんですね
どんな学校に行ってるんですかね
だからまあそれぐらいですからね
それはしょうがないんですね
だからよく日本でみんな言うんです
甘い話には乗るなとかね
安いものにはやっぱり何かありますよとか
ことわざであるにも関わらずやってしまっちゃうんですね
ただ ただのものほど高いものはないんですよとか
もう思い存分日本の文化の中でこの経験があったんだから
もうことわざとしても残ってるんだから
当たり前でしょうに ことを何か言葉甘いんだったら
その中に必ずもうすごい毒があるんです
宗教の世界でも同じなんです
あまりにも甘い話を言うと
完全なインチキなんです
人に平気で怒るんだったら
そこら辺何かあるはずなんです
人を叩き直そうと あまりにもこの丁寧に丁寧にこの格好つけて
もう慈悲を表してやろうではないか
愛を表してやろうではないかとやっちゃうと
僕は信じないんですね
どんな宗教家であろうか
あまりにも親切で 親切で
泣きながら涙流しながら人を助けたりすると
なんかあんた腐っどこか腐ってるんじゃないかなと
ですから この宗教 たとえ宗教の世界であって
あまり話が甘いんだったら
それはもう気をつけるのは当たり前のことで
だからたとえ商売繁盛とかね
家庭円満とかいうふうな
まあお寺の謳い文句なんですけどね
まあコピーですけど なんでそんなにもう甘い話を売ってるんですかと
だから 教師にしたっても
本当に子供を育てたい教師がきついでしょ
自分の仕事の安全だけ考える先生はえらい優しいんです
アメリカで問題があって
なんかどこかの学校で
先生たちはなんか他のところにクビにしたか
他の学校に入れたって
成績があまり悪いんだから
それで子供たちに聞けば
もう先生たちは何も言えませんと
それで中学校かな 高校ぐらいかな
読めないんですね 文字が
それぐらいなんですけど
みんなちゃんと卒業しているし
まだ成績まだかえって悪いし
そこでまあまああのこのADMINISTRATIONの方であんた方はまあ先生たちはクビにして
それに怒ってみんなまあ今運動やってますけど
その時でもしかすると先生たちは自分の身の安全を考えて
この子供たちに叱責言っちゃったら殺されるかもしれませんし
何やるかわかりませんから
それよりは子供たち通りにまあもう何も言わないでいた方が安全ではないかと思った可能性はあるんですね
そうすると 正しい 正直な先生にならないんですね
そういうことで このあまり甘い話は良くないと
ですから このちょっときつい話なんですけど
そこら辺には何か真実はあると
じゃあこの心が明るくなってくると
こういう特色があるんですね
で 自分の思考が明るいかないかわかるために
こういう特色を考えてください
なんとなくこの自分は気持ちいいというか
なんとなく気持ちいい
なんとなく明るさ感じる
やる気が出てくる たまにでもあるでしょ
我々にも 例えば掃除 掃除なんかも嫌で
たまにじゃあ掃除でもやってやろうという気持ちになる時あるでしょ
例えば家の人で全部 まあむちゃくちゃもう
もう物は取ったら取ったところで
服は脱いだらそのままで
あーだこうだ もうむちゃくちゃな状況
残酷な状況で毎日お母さんが怒る場合あるでしょ
もう片付けは 片付けはもうもうキリがないと
でもたまにあるんですね
そんなに苛立ちもなく
何のことなく もう旦那さんが捨てた服はそこからもうちゃんと持って
子供が捨てたのはそこをちゃんと拾って
それを何のことなく鼻歌でも歌いながら洗濯機に入れて
それを洗って干すとか
干して それからアイロンかけたりとか
そういう時もあるんですね
人間には その時はよく覚えといてください
何のきつくく感じなく
なんか仕事をやりたくなる
例えば男性の場合でも
よし 明日からじゃあ今日も会社に行こうではないかと
なんか何て言いますか
何するんで心ビクビクじゃなくて
ワクワクするというか
大したわけがないんです
なんとなくワクワクする
あの時は心の波動がポジティブなんです
ですから ポジティブ的になっちゃうと
わかりやすく 何なんですか
すぐ活発的なんですね
文句言わない もう自分の仕事をやってしまっちゃう
もし暇があったら人のところまでやってやってしまっちゃうと
ですから この自分がポジティブかないか理解
そういうところで理解するんです
それで文句言う方々いるんですね
いろんな形で文句言うんです
批判として 評論家として
あるいは単なる文句として
ブスブスブスブスと あるいは余計に理屈つける
こうすればよかったのに
なんでこうやらないんですかとかね
文句言う場合はすごい暗いんです
それ次に考えておいて
だから文句言う心なくなっちゃって
なんかワクワクする気持ちが生まれてくる
そこどうなればどうすればそうなるんですかね
そこが一番大事なんですけど
それからこの明るくなるとまたあります
あの体は硬くないんですね
スムースに動く 誰でも同じことなんです
だって子供子供はどうせ体が柔らかくて
ものすごい活発に動いてるでしょ
その子供でも暗くなってくると動かないんですね
鈍く鈍くなっちゃうんで
例えば学校に行きたくない日は
もうすごく動きが鈍い
体が重いんですね 学校に行きたくてしょうがない場合は
ドアボーンともう開けたままで
壁にもぶつかっちゃうわ
玄関を開けたそのまんまで
もう逃げて飛び出しちゃうんですね
あっちこっち忘れ物いっぱいあるわとか
家の中で それでまた母が追っていって
これこれこれとか思い出してあげなくちゃいけないぐらい
もう元気で動いてしまっちゃうんです
学校に行きたくない場合は
お母さんが起こしてあげなくちゃいけないし
自分で行きたい日は自分で起きるんですね
ということは 明るい時はすごい体が軽いんです
で 皆様散歩をしている経験がありますね
疲れる日もありまして
全然疲れない日もありますね
疲れない日はすごく心が明るいんです
その日はただ ただ単に体が体調が良くて元気ということじゃなくて
心が調子が良くて明るいということなんです
すごく明るくなってくればくるほど
体はものすごく軽く軽く軽くなっちゃいます
そこで全然疲れません
どこまでどんなぐらい仕事をしたっても
全く疲れません さらに明るくなっちゃうと
かなり余裕が生まれてくる
仕事をしながら冗談言ったり
ふざけたり 人をからかったり
もういろんなもう遊びでも全部遊びになってしまっちゃうんです
だから皆さんもこの日常生活の中で
すごくこのヒューマー入れてみてください
これはこの専門家の仕事じゃないんです
あれはおかしいんです
ある特別のプロが人を笑わせてくれると
あれはすごいあってはならない現象なんです
話術というんですかね
特別に修行して修行だから
あれ大変苦行なんですね
苦行して人を笑わす そういうところに行ってしか笑えないならば
もう人生諦めた方がいいんです
あんまりにも暗くて そんなものを聞いたっても笑えないんだけど
毎日常にすぐヒューマーがあって
もうすぐもうニコニコと喋ったりする
日常の中でヒューマーがいっぱい入っていると
かなり明るく明るいと思えるんです
ですから 明るくなりたければ
そういう方法でやればいいんです
どんなものでも軽く見る
真剣にしない 例えば 大学受験で子供たちがすごい悩んで
なんだただの受験かと
全然もう自分がもうなんかもう軽く見ちゃう
自分がそれ軽く見ちゃうと
向こう側もそれ軽く見ちゃうんです
例えば 1ヶ月間ぐらいずっともう勉強するんだけど
なんだ1ヶ月間ぐらいのことやねんとか
母親が大変だ大変だと思うんだから
結局成功は出てこないんです
だから労働はものすごい 300倍ぐらい難しくなってくるんです
試験は難しくなっちゃうんです
そういう風に物事を最初からもう真剣に見ないで
この僕の言葉 ちょっと間違うかもしれません
このいわゆる軽く見るんですね
あんまりこのクソ真面目という言葉いいかもしれませんだけどね
あんまりにも真面目でクソ真面目で見るんじゃなくて
まあ問題は問題ですから
それなりの真剣さは必要ですけど
だからといって神経質になる必要はないというふうな意味なんです
そういうふうに軽く見ちゃうと
そこで成功はします 成功したところに充実感が生まれてくる
それによって まあ徐々に明るくなっていっちゃうんです
じゃあ早く言わないと時間に間に合わないので
あの あの 一番皆様問題にするのは
じゃあどうすればワクワクしますかと
どうすれば心が明るくなるかと
体が軽くなってうまくいきますかと
あの 全部説明する時間ないんだから
一つだけ申し上げます
やることをよく覚えておいてください
充実感を感じましょうと
一つ 一つは常に充実感を感じましょう
それぐらい簡単にできる
ああ できたと 料理したところで
まあちょっと塩を入れすぎかもしれませんだけど
まあやっとできましたと
魚はちょっと焼きすぎなんです
まあ一応できましたと
焼きすぎたのは まあ他のことに
電話 ちょっと電話に夢中になっちゃったかな
なんてバカなことをやったんですか
魚焼きすぎてたところで
それちょっと焼きすぎになった
それはそれで別に気にする必要ないんですから
失敗にはね まあできたよというふうな
このやってることに どんなつまらないことであろうか
充実感感じてほしい ああ
時間もったいなということじゃないんです
例えば 自分が家の中で内職でもしてるかもしれません
収入のために それでまあ隣の奥さんが訪ねてきて
お茶飲みに来たんだと
で 奥さんとお茶菓子を出してお茶を飲んだところで
まあしゃべるはしゃべるはと
隣の人のことと 隣の隣の人のこととかいろいろ喋ったりすると
そうすると自分の時間がなくなっちゃうんですね
自分にとっては経済的にはそれは損なんですね
そうすると心の中でもうすごく苛立っちゃうんですね
あの人には苛立っちゃうんですね
なんだこれと あれは大変な毒なんです
だからその場合はどうせこの人はもうこのある時間
自分の時間を取っちゃう
帰れと言っちゃったら無欲なんだから
自分がその言葉を言わない
あんたうるさいんだから迷惑だから帰ってくださいなんて言えないでしょうね
正直なことを 人間どうせ正直なこと言えないんだから
だから合理的に考えちゃう
この人は私の時間はどうせ取っちゃうんだと
そこで じゃあ気持ちよく話し相手になりましょうということで
自分がその人に ああ聞いてよかったという感じになるように
ちゃんと充実した言葉を返してあげて
よくわかりました そうですね
その通りですねとか 何とか言ってあげたりして
自分も喜びを感じる この会話は無駄話はいくらか楽しい会話にしようではないかということで
そうしたところで その人はああ聞いてよかったという感じが出たら
もうまたまた何か喋る気が消えちゃうんですね
自分の話を聞いてない場合は言いたくなっちゃう
自分の話を無視しちゃったら
またね もう聞いたよとか言いたくなっちゃうんです
自分の話に反作用しちゃったら
腹が立ってさらに言いたくなっちゃうんです
あんたそうおっしゃいますけど
本当はこういうこういうことではないかと
みんなそういうことやっちゃうんです
やって あの時間延々と伸ばしてしまっちゃうんです
心の中でしゃべりたくない
この人いるんだから内職できないとかありながら
あの時間伸ばしちゃうんです
あれ 暗いんだから ですから
明るくなって あの時間きちんと十分使う
その人の話をよく聞いて
ああそうですねとか それなりの答えを言ってあげて
自分に何か言いたいことあったら
私もこういうふうに思いますねとか言ったら
向こうの人と喋り喋って
自分の寂しさ 何か消して欲しかったでしょ
もうこれもらってるんですね
じゃあ失礼します その人は明るく
その人を変えて返してあげることはできる
そこで自分が内職できなくてちょっと損したかもしれませんだけど
充実感です 自分は この幼稚園で出してくれるシールあるんですね
よくできましたというシール
あれは一生自分にもつけてみてください
自分の心に よくできました
それつけるともう完璧に明るくなっちゃうんです
で ですから僕は言うのは仕事
やることは成功しなさいではない
よく覚えておいてください
やることに充実感を感じてください
ああ 無駄でしたということだけはよくないんです
無駄にしないこと 何でも
それも諺にありますね
なんか転がってもなんかあります
なんか石一つでも拾って立ち上がりますよこういう
そういう感じの 僕は覚えてないんだけど
この諺が 最近はちょっと諺辞典を開けてみたんだけどな
いくつか見つかったんです
転んじゃったらああ痛いですよ
怪我しましたよとか泣くんじゃなく
そこら辺なんか綺麗な石でもあったら
それ拾って立ち上がればもう転んで別に悪かったわけじゃないでしょうに
痛いのは痛いんだけど
やっぱり綺麗な石を拾ったよということもありますから
そこに充実感があるんです
そういう経験によって
人間の心は徐々に明るい方向に行っちゃうんです
それにもう一つ必要なんです
この大胆な計画を立てないこと
あんまりこの遠い遠い未来のことはいいんです
無常論に戻るんです 仏教
来年のこと 再来年のこと
5年後のこと そんなのは放っておきましょう
5年のことで計画を立てて
もう頑張っちゃうとすごい暗いんです
充実感感じなくなっちゃうんです
だから実際に私たちが今の瞬間は行動しているんです
たとえ20年計画であろうか
1 秒 1 秒仕事をしていくんだから
その 1 秒1 秒充実してないと
20年目の計画は成功すると思いますか？成功しない
ですから 人間には常に充実感を感じられる
なぜならば大胆なことをしてないんだから
ほんの簡単単純なことしかしてないんですね
ただメモを書く場合はただ書いていることだけだから
それに集中して充実感を得られれば
それだけで十分です それは本にしようとか
私の自伝に書いておこうとか
こんなもう遠い未来のことを考えながらメモを取っちゃうと
そこで苦しみを味わっちゃう
それで暗くなっちゃう
ですから 世の中で難しいことは一つもないんです
なぜならば 仕事は 1 秒単位でやっているんだから
1 秒単位の仕事っていうのはいとも簡単でできるんです
それなんで理解しないかと
僕はわからないんです
1時間仕事をする人はいないんです 1
秒 1 秒 1 秒仕事をしているんだから
例えばなんとか自分がシチューとか
なんとか時間かける料理作るんだと
それで三時間かかるんだ
これ三時間かかる料理だから大変
三時間かかるなと思ったら大変ですごいストレスかかっちゃうんです
でも三時間かかっての言ったって一秒単位でやってるものだから
だからお肉を取るとか
肉を取りますと これはちゃんと取ればいいし
叩くんだったらそれ気持ちよく叩けばいいし
あまり腹が立ってストレス溜まってたいたいた言っちゃったらもう料理になりませんから
切る時はそれだけちゃんとそれ楽しく切っちゃえばいいんだから
鍋に入れる時はそれはそれなりに鍋を取って
すごく充実感があって
鍋を取ったりしてそれに入れたりと
それ一つ一つやっちゃうと全然疲れませんし
一つ一つの仕事をちゃんとやってるし
そうすると最終的な結果が当たり前なんです
成功しているということは
ですから この明るくなるのはもう大変なことじゃなくて
ものすごい単純な簡単なことなんです
それに必要なのは そういう瞬間瞬間に絞ること
充実感が番目 番目は大胆なことを妄想するんじゃなくて
瞬間瞬間に自分の仕事を絞ってみる
それに続いて番目に言えるのは
余計な考え方 余計なリクエスト
余計な妄想 頭の働き ストップしましょう
人間考えて暗くなるんです
姑さんのことを考えると
親御さんがすごい暗くなるんです
嫁さんのこと考えちゃうと
姑さんが暗くなっちゃうんです
考えなきゃいいのに 子供のことを考えると心配で心配でもう戦争も弱くなってしまっちゃうんです
ハラハラしちゃうんです
じゃあ考えたんだからで
何かいい結果ありますか？自分が一生懸命心配して考えてるんです
それでいい結果ありますか？全然ないんだから
結局あまりにも暗くて暗くて体が動かないだけだから
かえって悪いだけなんです
例えば外へ出たところでお嫁さんが姑さんのことばっかり考えて考えて
もうすごく腹が立っていて
あまりにも腹が立って外へ出て
そこでまた何時間も外へ入っちゃう
いろんなことをグラグラしたりして
喫茶店で時間過ごしたりして
その時でもあればっかり考えて
で 家に帰るところ同じ顔でしょうに
それで家で姑さんが顔を合わせちゃったところで
もう明るく気持ちよくただいまと言えないんだから
考えない方がいいんです
外へ出たところで 綺麗な喫茶店で紅茶コーヒーでも飲んだならば
何かいいこと 楽しいことあったならば
その感じでただいまと明るく入っちゃえばもう何のこともないんです
みんなお互いに良くなるんです
だから この瞬間瞬間に絞るためには
余計なことを考えない方がいいんです
妄想と この我々は考えているということを極力やめた方がいいんです
それは納得いかない場合は私はことわざで言います
考えるのはバカで考えないのは知識人だと
バカだから一生懸命考える
いくら考えても 所詮バカだから結局もう何も意味がないんです
知ってるんだから考える必要ないんです
ですから 考えない人は頭がいいんです
だから考えるなということは
あまり大変危ないことじゃないんです
私も同じことで たまにいろんなことを考えるんです
行動すると必ず失敗するんです
決まってるんです 考えちゃったら失敗
で なんで考えるんですか？って
やっぱりどこかでその問題はわからないとこうだったりするんですね
わからないんだったらわからないんだからそれで終わりですから
そこで余計なこと考えちゃって
さらに 失敗するということはよくあるんですからね
まあ大体そういうところで明るくなるんです
それからこの 仏教では信仰の代わりに信仰は仏教はあまり使わない
信仰といったっても ちょっと日本語の信仰とあまりそんな差がないんだけど
英語で言えば faith というんですね
もう一つ言葉があります faith belief
これは日本訳になって
まあ信仰ぐらいのものになりますけどね
それであまり仏教では意味を使わないんですね
だから信じるということは
仏教の意味で言うならば
もう知らないんだから信じるんですね
信じますよ 知ってるならば
信じるという言葉が消えちゃう
例えばお茶美味しいですよと言ったら
皆様信じますか？信じる必要ありますか？お茶美味しいということ
知ってるんだから 僕より
ですから 自分知ってるものは別に信じる必要はないんです
ただ 私は自分の国にある
なんか名前の聞いたことがない果物の名前って
あの果物はすごい美味しいですよって言ったら
ああ まあどうせこの国の人言ってるんだから
もしかすると本当だろうと信じるしかないんですね
よくありますね 果物の王様ですよというのはドリアンですか？ドリアンは果物の王様ですよ
言ったらみんな信じるかもしれません
でも初めてドリアンに出会ってみてください
どうなるかと 王様ですか
あるいはもうどっちですか？と
だから知らないものは信じるのであって
仏教は知らないのは嫌なんです
知らないことをやっちゃったら危なくてしょうがないし
どこへ行けばいいかわからない
だから知る知るということは仏教なんです
だから智慧の教えだから
仏教っていうのはブッダの教えっていう意味だから
ブッダっていうのは悟った人ということだから
悟ることは仏教の宗教なんです
知ること だから当然これはもう気に入らないのは当たり前です
ですから 神か信仰が入っちゃったら暗いんです
弱いんです 自分で試さなくてもいいんだから
聖書にあるんだから まあ天国あるでしょうと
で 信じちゃうとか 誰かさんが言ってるんだからそうでしょうと
それでひどい目にあった経験
皆様にあるでしょ 苦い経験
人を信じて もう何年か前
なんか統一教会という運動がありまして
かなり人々はすごいもう経済的にね
まあきつい状況ことに出会っております
そこでそれからあちこちでそういう裁判までになったりとかね
やっぱり信じてしまっちゃったら
そこでもう捕まれちゃうんですね
でも宗教の世界では信じるなと言っちゃったら
なんかきつい言葉だからなんか嫌がりますけど
別にどうってことないんです
ですから 仏教でこの信 belief
とfaithの代わりにこういう言葉を使う
[背景音楽]これカンフィデンスと読むんです
カンフィデンス 日本語の意味は確信
英語 ですね あちらの普通英語の普通の日常英語の意味なんですね
信頼 自信というのは で
僕は僕は使っている言葉っていうのは
ちょっと専門用語みたいな
この違う意味で使ってるんです
ですから 英語にもそういういろいろあります
レベルが 同じ単語でも普通の辞書を引いたらその意味が出てこない
ですから しょうがないんだけど
確信です 信仰の代わりに確信というしっかりしろと
例えば 私はいちいちこの仏教の話は
この合理的に分析して喋ったりするのは
ただの知識的知識話ではないかと思うかもしれませんだけど
それでいいんです ものすごい知識的に理解して理解して言っちゃうと
なんとなく納得いくでしょ
あの納得は信なんです
仏教の信仰なんです 理解すること
しっかりと ですから この明るくなりたければ
信仰が必要です どういう信仰かというと
こういう信仰 いわゆる納得いきなさい
納得しなさいと 納得するためにはい
納得ということじゃないんです
NHK にありません なんとか納得して合点という番組
でもいきなり納得はいきません
だからいろいろことを教えたところで納得するでしょう
あの番組のあの組み立てを見ても
まあまあそれほど厳しくやってる
まあただ面白おかしい番組ですけど
やっぱりその場合も じゃあ最終的に説明して
じゃあ納得いきましたか？と聞いたら
みんなじゃあそれだったらもう合点つけてくださいと
そういう働きは仏教では大事に使ってるんです
よく理解して納得いきましょうと
ですから 日常 私たちはやらなくちゃいけないことについても
自分どんなことについても
よく理解して納得しちゃうと
そこで確信 確実に明るい波動が生まれちゃう
納得してないと仕事をさせてみてください
すごいひどい目に遭うんです
例えば なんでこの子供たちの場合
いろいろ問題を起こしますかというと
子供たちを納得 説得というのはさせない
ただ命令だけする 勉強しなさいと
勉強しなきゃダメですよと
なんであんなおかしいこと勉強しなきゃダメで何がダメですかね
そこに納得ないんです
だからもっとドラマティック
ドラマ的に ドマティカルに勉強しなきゃこうなりますよ
ああなりますよ 自分がちょっと演じで演じでもして
子供にすごく迫力あるように納得させちゃえば
それで終わりなんです
あなたはどっちにするんですかと
僕はもう 40年もっと前の話
ちょっと前の話 5  6歳時の話でしたけど
自分のうちにこの物を乞う
この乞食って言った時ですか
いるんだからもう来るんです
それで着てない何かボロ服をちょっとなんかちょっとだけ着て
体も汚いし もう髪の毛はもう洗ったことは全くもう生まれてからもないぐらいの
まあで まあうちの前に立って
まあいろんな言葉で何とかちょうだいと
ご飯食べてないんだからとか何とか言っちゃうんです
あるいはご飯もらうために何か歌を歌ったりとか
なんとかと そこで大体まあ何か家にあった残り物やら米やら何かあるものをあげちゃう
何もない場合はお金あげると
で 昔はね 今はお金あげることは羞恥になって
昔はお金あげるのはすごく恥ずかしがっちゃうんですね
僕らの時代では で それでそういう人々はまあね
お金あげたりご飯あげたりして
帰ると母がちょっとちらっとこういうことを言うんですね
勉強しなかないで怠けたらそんなもんですねと
勉強しないで怠けちゃったらそんなもんだよと
だから物を乞うのは怠け者だというふうに
もう僕らの国では考えているんですね
怠け者は物を乞うてもらって食べちゃうと
そこで別に勉強しろとは全然言わないんです
怠けるなと だからああいう風になるんですねとか
なんか自分のことじゃなくて
全くもう第三者の話で言っちゃうんです
チラッと言うことは 特設自分に責めていたことでもないし
他の兄弟たちに言ったことでもないし
それはチーンと帰るんです
納得いくんです だから喧嘩なしにみんな自分の意思で
私の昔はね 兄弟はみんな勉強したんです
一度も言われたことはない
一度もなかったんです
勉強しなさいと だから学校に行くのは全然苦しくも何ともなかったし
それはそれで だから我々も今の現代社会で
やっぱり納得したらやるんです
納得は馬鹿げた納得は良くない
いい加減なことを非合理的なことを言ったり
嘘を言ったら何でしたっけ？ハリセンなんとかなんとかと
そんなもういい加減なことを言うんだから
そうじゃなくて きちんと合理的に
例えば自分の子供一回嘘を言っちゃったら
嘘を言うなと言ったってわからないでしょ
そこで僕だったら黙ってるんです
騙されたような感じで
そこで言うんです あれ
あれ嘘でしょと それだけ悪い
そこで次にその人は子供の場合
何か必要であって どこか行きたくてなんとかと言っちゃうでしょ
言うと あんた嘘を言う
嘘を言うんだからね この間も嘘を言ったんだから
まあ信じて信じられませんねと言って
あれやってあげない 自分で行くわ
これはこの子には必要ですよと言っていてもやらない
そこでも一回限りで嘘は言わない
だから嘘を言ったら信頼を失いますよと
自分が不幸に遭いますよということは
もうそこで確実に経験で教えてあげちゃう
それは納得のやり方なんです
だからこの私たちもこの子供の問題いったのは
皆様に別に関係ないと思うんじゃなくて
我々も死の瞬間までやることにちゃんと納得していく必要があるんです
私たち大人の これは人間みんな同じで
物事に納得しちゃう瞬間に
その物事をできる 嫌嫌でなくて
嫌々でなくて仕事をできる
それ成功もする 自信も全部つけてきて
やる気も出てきて そこで充実感生まれてくる
全部明るくなっちゃう
たった一つ ですから この明るい思考っていうのは一つだけ取っちゃえばすっと明るく投げられてしまうんです
いろいろたくさんありますけど
まあ大体これぐらいでもできると思いますよ
また もっとこれは 1番目の大事なことで
信パーリの専門用語はサッダーなんです
それは日本訳で信と信仰と訳しますが
仏教のサッダーっていうのはそういうものとは少々違うということだけ理解してほしいです
確信である で 信だけ生まれちゃったら
すぐ心が明るくなりますよときちんと書いてるんです
明るくなってものすごく行動的になるんだと
体も心も全部全身 全身たいもう軽くなって柔軟性持ちます
それにプラスアルファ
またいくつかありますね
精進すること いわゆる怠けることの反対
それから慈悲の心 慈しみの心
それから愛の心ですか
人を助けてあげたくなる
人に何かしてあげたくなる
その心とか そういうのを実践してみれば
明るい方向へ行っちゃうんです
ですから 商売したっても儲かろう儲かろうというと暗いんです
じゃなくて 人間は努力しなくちゃいけないという
で まあ何か仕事をしなくちゃいけないんだからという風に
なんかすごく軽く それで儲かってよかったと
今月はなかなか週になくて
それ今月はこれぐらいですかねとか
まあそれでも人はもうなんか頑張らなくちゃいけないと
毎日活発で何かもう生きがいとしてなければいけないという
この明るい方向であれば
もう商売で何であろうがもう問題なくうまくいくんです
すべてのものが だからこの精進
努力すること で それから知恵があることとかね
また集中力あるならば
物事に集中力 と まあまあそれぐらいなんですね
欲と怒りが消えちゃいますからね
それぐらいのことで完全に明るい方向へなっていくんです
それが明るい波動で明るい波動になってくると
全部うまくいくんです
なんだかんだでも 毎日毎日
瞬間瞬間 充実感が出てくると
脳細胞はすっごくもう元気で活動する
脳細胞というのは不思議な細胞で
働かせちゃうと元気放っておいちゃうと元気がなくなっちゃって死んでしまっちゃう
そこ で また脳細胞の不思議な組み合わせがありまして
一部成長しちゃうと一部だけ残りは無視されてるんです
無視されてる分はどうします？無視されちゃう
死んじゃうんでしょ そこで脳細胞
お互いにいつでもコンタクトを取ってきてるんです
そこで成長した部分が他の脳細胞を死んじゃうと
なんであいつら仕事もしないのに
勝手に早く死んでも私たちがまたやらなくちゃいけないと
ここでもう一緒に死んじゃうんです
道連れになっちゃう それで強烈なボケっていうものが生まれちゃうんです
だから大体この人生一つだけに集中してやってる方々にはボケがありまして
大学の教授とか 日本のケースで言うならば
大学の教授とか お寺のお坊さんとか
なかなかボケないというかね
いろんなものに頭が使ってるんだから
会社にしたっても もうかなりもう偉い人で
知識があって 能力があって
まあもういろんな人々を指導したり
育たせたりする方々は
もういくら年取っても頭がしっかりしてるんです
なぜならば 自分の専門分野のことだけではなくて
後の世代の人々の個人的な生き方のところまで自分が心配しなくちゃいけないんだから
私はもうプロで こういう分野の専門家で
他のことを知りませんよとかじゃないんだから
ですから 指導者が大体ボケないんです
政治家ボケないでしょ
普通だったらね まあ会社だったら仕事をさせてくれますかね
あの おじいちゃんたちに
国は権利全部取ってるんだから
何々大臣とか 年聞いちゃったらもう今はちょっと若返ってますけど
もうちょっと前はどうですかね
日本の政治家って 目が見えないわ
もう歩けないわ ボロボロでしょうに
それでもよくやること
ですから もう頭は完全に使ってほしいんですね
頭を完全に使うためには
やっぱり頭にもすごい喜びの刺激を与えてあげなくちゃいけない
ですから 物事は何だかんだもちゃんと理解して
やることによって充実感を得てやったりすると
もう余裕が出てきたりして
余裕が出てきちゃうと
他のことも心配するぐらいことできるようになってきて
もう自分の何て言いますか
この領域というか この視野がもう限りなく広げちゃう
だから限りなく広げる視野を持ってほしいんです
というぐらいの明るいことは終わります
いくらかそれぐらいでまあ大体は言いました
一番大事なポイント じゃあ中道の話にはもうなかなかなれないもんですけど
まあ中道の話はもっと難しいんです
ですから このすごい男性的な話になるかもしれません
それをちょっと今日もちょっとした心配なことはありましたけど
えっと まあつなげてるんです
悩みのない心っていうのは
明るい心 それは中道的な中道を持って
どう明るい心を作るかっていう方向なんですね
僕はこのテーマで言いたがっているのは
仏教の中道の話を言いたがっているわけじゃないんです
この仏教の中道っていうのは超越道という意味なんです
ちょっと書いてみます
いわゆる超越道なんです
中道じゃないんです まあ中という漢字にはもうものすごい意味があるんです
だから仏教の漢字の場合は
この経典が漢訳 漢訳した時代の意味で理解しなくちゃいけないんです
現代の漢字辞典引いちゃったら困るところもあるんです
まあちゃんと書いてますが
やっぱりその時代の意味で取らなくちゃいけないので
当時では まあなんか意味あったでしょうと思いますけど
あの 正しい意味は超越道
仏道は超越道なんです
何が超越道ですかね そこで大体 2つあります
まず思考 2番目生き方
いわゆる科学的に言えば論理と実践という
でもこれ科学じゃなくて人間のこと言ってますから
人間っていうのは思考だから思考と生き方
その両方の超越どうなんです？じゃあ思考の超越って何ですか？これ大変なことで
人間には何を考えても考えるものは仏教では偏見というんです
その用語であんたというんです
偏見というのは もうまあ
偏見という言葉が出ます
片っ方という意味ですからね
偏る  こういう感じないんですか？あの片という漢字がありますね
僕はそれは気には行ってるんだけど
そういう字がないんだけど
そういう方じゃなくて
そうそう そういう意味はないね
だからこの完全じゃなくて半分なんですね
偏見じゃなくて  一応偏見はこの漢字なんですけど
まあそれでいきましょう
まあ僕に まあ一応偏っている意見と
だから我々の知識 勉強
哲学 見てください 全部偏ってるんです
何かに 現代知識っていうのは昔も同じなんです
人間の我々のこの思考っていうのは
この偏らないと働かないようになってるみたいんですね
そういうのは全部偏見であると知ってほしいんです
例えば医学にしたら それはもう偏見であって
ある方向へ偏っている思考の働きであって
経済学にしたらある方向へ偏ってやってる働きであって
生き方は全体的には考えてないんですね
だからいろいろ問題が
我々の世界のどんな知識からも結局は生まれてくるのは問題だけなんです
いつでもそういうこと
例えば細菌というのは殺すべきですよ
細菌は病気 病気の原因だよと考えちゃったでしょ
あれ偏った考え方なんですね
そこで細菌は殺すべきです
細菌を殺す いろんなもう
薬品を使って それで治療治してる
治療しているんだ 治療しているんだと大嘘ついてるんですね
ただ細菌殺してるだけなんですけど
殺し屋さんですけど それで細菌も生きているものだから
もうずっと殺しっぱなしではね
やっぱり どうしようもないでしょうに
殺されるっぱなしで いろいろ工夫するんですね
生き延びるために 賢いんだから
賢さっていうのは人間だけじゃなくて細菌にもあるもんなんです
そこでもう賢く自分がもうそれなりの準備を整えちゃったら
もうお手上げ また殺そうと
また新しいものを作ろうとすると
それは偏見 インドの医学では中国も同じかもしれませんだけど
全く違う考え方を持ってるんですね
細菌による病気にならないんだと言っちゃったら
みんなあれはとんでもない嘘やと思っちゃうんですね
でも インドのアユルヴェーダとか漢方とか
そこら辺では細菌って全然知らない
病気は細菌によるものじゃなくて
体の調子がおかしいんだと
だから体の調子を直そうと
調子良くしようと 流れを良くしようと
それも一つの概念 だからどっちが正しいかというと
もうわかりませんだけどね
もう確かに細菌はいると
細菌は我々の細胞を侵す
それも確かな事実であって
この東洋で言っていることも確かな事実なんです
なぜならば 細菌というのはもう古からあるものでしょうね
我々よりは年上でも昔からいるものでしょうに
我々よりしっかりしていて
この地球から人間が消えちゃっても細菌はいるんだから
細菌は我々に笑うかもしれません
あいつら一時的に瞬間現れてきて
むちゃくちゃ全部むちゃくちゃにしては消えちゃったんだと
なんか突然うちに訪問してきて
邪魔をして帰ったもんみたいなもんなんですね
ですから 細菌は古からずっとあるものだから
我々もその中にいるでしょう
もし私に私を細菌に侵されたならば
やっぱり私の細胞の方が調子が悪いっていうことは正しいんです
皮膚の上でいっぱいあるでしょうに
もし私が皮膚病を起こしたならば
私の皮膚の調子が何か悪いだけで
風邪ウイルスはいつでもあるでしょうに
もし風邪を引いちゃったら
こちらの調子が悪い ですから
体の調子を直してあげてもいいんです
だから漢方も効く ヨーロッパの薬も効くということになっているし
効かないところはどっちでも効かないし
だから偏見なんですね
他の教えも偏見ばっかしなんです
どんなものにしたって
そこで中動的に苦しみがなぜ中動的にではなくて
なぜ苦しみが思いますかというと
私たちは偏見を持ってるんです
例えば上司は私のことを嫌いだと思っちゃうでしょ
それは意見でしょ 意見であるならば偏見であります
あの人は私のこと好きですよと
それ意見でしょ それだったらそれは偏見です
正しい考え方ではないんです
そういうものからではないんですか
私たちの苦しみ悩み生まれるのは
あの人は私のことを嫌がっていますよと思っちゃったら
それによってすごくここでもう悩み始めちゃう
あの人私のことを気に入ってるよと思っちゃったら
それについていろいろここでいろんな悩みが生まれてくる
あるいは私はあの人のこと好きですよと思ったら
また同じことできる いつでも我々はほとんど悩みのはこの好き嫌いの偏見で
結局は自分に気に入るか気に入らないかというえらいわがまま勝手で物事を考えているんです
それすごいバカバカらしいんですけど
上司は私のこと嫌いですよ
自分の我儘勝手に私を好きになりなさいということを言ってるんですね
私に親切に喋りなさいと
だからかえって自分に聞いてください
私は何者何様ですかと
この存在の中で何もないのに
ただの塵一つに等しくない
もう何のことない存在なのに
考えるときはえらく威張って
もう存在の唯一唯一のものだと思って考えている
それこそ巨大な偏見がないんです
だからみんなもう苦しみ悩みの中にいるんです
学校の先生 あの先生は良くないんだと
あの先生はいいんですよと
あの学校は良くないんだと
あの子供たちは良くないんだと
だから自分の子供の仲間になってくれたから困るんだとか
あの店の食べ物はおいしいんだと
この店の食べ物は美味しくないんだと
全部世界は偏見ばっかしなんです
世界はどうでもいいんだけど
私は偏見ばっかしなんです
私は自分勝手で好き嫌いで生きてるんですね
好きなものは全部自分のものになってほしい
嫌いなものは全部なくなってほしいと
でも 自分が王様でもないし
天皇陛下でもないし アメリカの大統領でもないし
何者でもないんですね
アメリカの大統領といってもただの人間だから
もう何のこともできないんだから
病気になったらその人どうするんですか？私はアメリカの大統領だから
病気になんかなってはいけませんと
そうなるんですかね カゼひいてはいけませんと
私はアメリカの元大統領だから
アルツハイマーにボケてはいけませんと言ったっても
レーガンはもう完全にボケてるでしょうに
ただの人間なんです それまたただの人間
何ができるんですかね
じゃあ私は皆様にちょっとチャレンジします
皆様はただの人間だと思ってないかもしれませんだけど
すごい発展しているんだと
じゃあ火を起こしてみてください
人の知恵借りないで 毎日使ってるでしょ
火を起こしてみてください
絶対できないと思います
ライターかガスコンロの自動的な火をつけるなんとかとかなければできますか？マッチとか
結局それぐらいもできないくせに
一人の人間にもそんなもんなんです
だから進歩とともにどんどん人間が何もできない人になっちゃうんです
この昔 山の中で生活していた時とは違いますよ
その時は火を仕掛かっちゃったら
もう枯れた何か枝を持って
何かちょっとした穴を開けて
その中にもう軽い葉っぱとか何か言って
もう一生懸命こうやって
こうやって ただ手でものすごい力強く回して回して回して火を起こしちゃったんだけど
今は誰にもできないんです
道具持って持ってきてあげたっても
そんな手に力ないんです
ですから 自分では何もできない
皆様 美しい服を着ているんだけど
自分で作られますかね
何もできないんだから
だからすっごい謙虚になった方がいいのに
まあそこは謙虚にならない
すごいわがまま高慢で
それで好き嫌いで 生きている
そこにあれとあらゆる苦しみが生まれてくる
そこで私が言うのは 好き嫌い捨てるのではなくて
偏見捨てましょうと 偏見捨てたところで
この超越道というもの
じゃあ何を考えればいいかということ出てくるんです
例えばわかりやすく言えば
あの店は美味しいです
この店は美味しくないですということは偏見であるならば
医学も偏見で 経済学も偏見で
科学も偏見であるならば
宗教も偏見 哲学の偏見であるならば
美術の偏見であるならば
じゃあ何を考えればいいんですかという問題が出てくるでしょう
それ考えるべきものは超越性と言うのです
偏見は偏見であるとわかる
ある角度でそうなりますよとは理解する
その角度の中で その条件の中ではそうなんですけど
違う立場から見れば違いますよと
僕はよく例えに言うのは
バラの花とかね 人間の角度から見れば
ただ装飾品で綺麗なものだと
目を楽しませるものだと
蝶々の立場から見れば
それは食卓であると それでバラの中に住んでいる小さな虫なんかいるならば
それは居心地のいい家であると
美しいとかなんとか そんなことないんです
もし見て楽しむものだったら
どうやって蝶々でも蜂でもミツバチでも
あれは食卓にするんですかと
食べませんだから それだったら
そこでバラの花を食う虫がいるんだからね
その虫にすれば それは大変ごちそうであります
美しくはないんです じゃあ一体全体バラって何ですかと
そこでバラの木から聞けば
バラの花ってなんですか
また違うものでしょ 自分の体の一部だって自分の生殖器官な機械なんですね
だから人間も欲も恥ずかしがらないで
あんなものを飾っておきますからね
あれは植物の生殖器官ですから
人間はそのことが入れ替えても
自分の生殖器官なんかどこかで飾っておくことしますか？写真でも撮ってやらないんだから
恥ずかしくて気持ち悪くて
やっぱり見る角度変わるともう物事変わるっていうことなんです
だからまあその時その時まあ必要に応じてまあその意見結んであって
すぐその場を去っていけばそれでいいんですよ
いわゆる主義は良くないんですね
私は資本主義や私は共産主義や
私は何々主義やとか そんな主義はあるわけないんです
すぐ明日何主義か分かりませんだからね
今正しいというものは
すぐ明日になっちゃうともうまた違うと言えますからね
そういうものにとらわれて
例えば共産主義の方がいたと思ったら
ところで 私は徹底的に共産主義だと
これこそ真実やと それでどんどん世の中が変わっていっちゃって
共産主義は時代遅れになっちゃって
世の中から消えちゃっても
でもその人はずっと苦しみばっかり味わってるでしょうに
それからも新しい時代に馴染めなくなっちゃったりして
かわいそうなんですね
その だから偏見持っちゃうと
生きるために必要な大事なものを失っちゃう
なんて言いますか 適応
適応ということがなくなっちゃうんです
ですから まず我々考えているものについては
あまり執着しないこと
あまりこれこそ真実だと思わないこと
常に新しい情報 新しい事実と組み合わせて組み合わせて新しくする
それでも自分の意見に絶対取られない
という思考の自由 本物の自由
偏見を持たないこと それは思考の超越性
生き方はそれから出てくるんですね
それで生きる それを持って
例えばそれは喧嘩にならない
例えばもう 夏休み 旦那さんがオーストラリアに行こうとする
オーストラリアは広くてもうよく遊べるんですよ
奥さんが夏はオーストラリア嫌ですよと
オーストラリア冬だから
そこで夫婦は喧嘩すると
喧嘩する必要ないんです
旦那さんの立場でものすごい大きいところで思い存分遊びたいと
それはそれで正しいし
寒さ嫌がっている奥さんにとっては
もうせっかくもう日本の夏休みでオーストラリアに行っちゃっても真冬だから
どんなに全然休みにならないんではないかと
それはそれで正しいし
だからそうですね こういう立場で見れば
そういう意見で こういう立場で見れば
そういう意見で じゃあどうすればいいんですかと
具体的に考えればいいんです
そうすると何とか結論が出てくる
旦那さんもあんまりオーストラリアみたいな大きいところで遊ばなくてもいいんじゃないかと
まあいくらか大きければいいんではないかと
そこでまあいくらか暖かい国の方がいいんじゃないかと
まあ他の国になる可能性あるんですね
そうするとどっちでも楽しくバケーションが過ごせるし
そんな感じの生き方なんですね
私は正しいと思わない
相手も間違っていると思わないで
生活する それを超越道と呼ぶんですね
また言葉でいっぱい言いますけど
落ち着けるなと よくあることなんですね
人にこれはこうです そうやりに落ち着けて言っちゃう人いるし
決めつける そういうのは全部良くないんです
特に人間する すごくいけない決めつけがありまして
人を判断する 人の性格
あの人怒りっぽいと あの人欲が深いんだと
あの人怠け者だと あの人寿司が好きですと
あの人は刺身は好物ですと
よく人のことを決めつけちゃう
その人に怒られる なぜならば自分が何者かと自分でも知らないでしょ
特に有名なんです 性格分析というのは
ヨーロッパでも有名で
よくよく頑張ってやってますけどね
僕はいい加減なことをやめた方がいいと思いますよ
なぜならば 偉そうに性格分析するんだけど
他人のこと 我々自分の心に正直に聞いてみてください
自分が何者かと 知らないでしょ
どんな性格かと 何が好きで何が嫌いかと
しっかりしてないんです
たまたま出会ったものでは
これは嫌いで これは好きだと決めただけだから
他のものに出会っちゃったら
あれは嫌いで 今まで好きだったものは嫌いで
これからこれ好きですよとなっちゃいますからね
自分のことさえ知らないんだから
人のことを決めつけるなと
そういうふうな生き方で生きていられると
それは超越道であって
何にも取柄なく どんなものからも苦しみの波が生まれてこない完全たる生き方だというのです
まあ難しいですから 一応理屈だけでも覚えていただければ結構だと思います
一応そこら辺で話を終わり終了します
長い時間 ご静聴ありがとうございました
ありがとうございます